okay let me take you back to our that
breaking news from the occupied by Bank
the Israeli Army is saying that two
Israelis have been killed in a suspected
shooting attack we can go back to Anita
Abraham who's in Bethlehem Forest we've
got her on the phone Anita if you can
hear me what's the latest on this
according to the Israeli forces they are
reading different cities and towns that
need the Hawaii area where they
suspected shooting attack took place
this is still unfolding so we've been
getting a lot of information that some
were conflicting at first there was a
suspicion that that could have been a
fight between uh two Israelis because it
happened in a car wash but there are
other estimates that maybe there was a
car that shot towards the two Israelis
who would win now we are talking about
an intense area in Florida we've been
seeing a lot of shooting attacks as well
as stabbings by Palestinians against
Israelis in that area but we've also
been seeing enter water attacks by
Israeli settlers against Palestinians
which we've seen in the past few months
has led to
burning homes and houses in Hawaii all
in all it remains a tense situation and
the Israeli Army is treating it as a
suspected shooting and they are saying
that they're following to see who the
shooter was Anita just explained to our
viewers why kawara particularly should
be such a flash point
in the occupied West Bank it's been
seeing a lot of tension by Israeli
forces we're talking about increasing
sacraments we're talking about a road
that has been confiscated for the
benefit of the settlers to create more
infrastructure more roads for them and
as we've been seeing there have been
intensified Israeli raids all over the
occupied West Bank and Palestinians say
that in response to the Israeli
aggressions to the Israeli killings of
Palestinians they were conducting
shooting attacks a lot of which happened
in her water probably also because there
has been a lot of
Israeli military presence
would tell you that the Israeli forces
are there for the benefit of the Israeli
settlers we've also seen the Israeli
settlers rampaging on her water burning
homes Palestinians were saying that the
Israeli Army intervened very very late
and it often allows Israeli settlers not
just to uh attack Palestinians but also
to get away with attacking them
obviously we have in the early hours of
what's been happening I know you're
going to be keeping a cross at Forest
Knitter but for now near Ibrahim from
Bethlehem thank you very much